In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion from A4, on which we commemorate the holy martyr Belagia
of Tarsus.
Saint Belagia came from a noble family of Tarsus, Celicia.
She settled in Rome and became betrothed to one of the sons of the Emperor Diocletian.
Having heard of the rapid spread of the Christian faith, she sought to learn what it taught.
A short time later, in a dream, she saw the Bishop of Rome baptizing a great number
of Catecumans.
He turned towards her and called her to be reborn to eternal life.
When she awoke, Belagia took leave of her parents, under the pretext of going to visit
her nurse, and went with haste to the Bishop who baptized her.
She gave her rich garments to the prelate, so that he might distribute them to the poor,
and arrived at the house of her nurse, very simply dressed in the style of the common people.
As her nurse would not receive her, she went home.
Her mother, seeing her clothes, realized what had happened and tried to persuade her daughter
to forsake Christ and to dress herself in a manner appropriate to her status.
The young girl, however, remained unyielding and proclaimed that she would never abandon
the spouse of her soul.
Her mother informed Diocletian's son that her daughter refused his offer of marriage,
and he, in desperation, committed suicide.
When the emperor heard this news, he was filled with a violent rage and had the saint
shut up in a red-hot bronze ox, in which she accomplished her definitive union with Christ.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.